can i ask you about
uh jackass injuries because i remember
when we were
when we were in ohio or we were
somewhere i think in phoenix that like
you got to go to the chiropractor
because you're like dude
my neck is so [ __ ] up in 2010
when we did jackass three i just kept
getting neck injuries that whole movie
like bam kicked me
yeah and then that [ __ ] it up and then
like we
we did this thing in this hallway with a
boogie board and all these balls and
i caught my head and one of the doorways
and hurt my neck really bad
and then uh and then i they slingshoted
me into that swimming pool and one time
i just went headfirst in the swimming
pool and cranked my neck
so like from 2010 to 2015
my neck hurts so goddamn bad and i did
everything i could and finally i got a
surgery
oh did you did you get uh did you get
the
paramount to pay for the neck surgery no
i don't know how to do that
[Laughter]
yeah they like they fuse your discs
together damn i saw a pretty
goddamn good mobility and i couldn't
sleep it was the problem and now i can
sleep for the most part
that's [ __ ] poisonous right now
except for the poison [ __ ] dying it's
all my [ __ ] eyes
really damn i remember when uh we had
like the
the jackass takeover like uh we were
doing the jackass world this was right
before
i got sober so i was at my absolute
worst oh yeah in new york i remember
that yeah
i was at my house you were at your worst
that was an understatement
yeah and and my yeah my worst is is
something else because
my best isn't that great but you decided
you could only walk on money do you
remember that yeah
but then there's another guy right
behind him cleaning it because they
didn't have enough to like keep going
and then
clean that money and then throw now
they're going to throw more money it was
like a cycle
like coming to america when they're
walking on rose petals
but with money what's that five minutes
you had to be watching money it was like
ones and [ __ ] too
oh my god i don't remember that but now
that you remind me yeah
oh my god right that's great but there
was a shoot that was going on when we
were in new york for that time because
we were trying to film all these bits
for uh jackass world they thought that
this is going to be great we're going to
have a website that's going to
you know and like there's a winch on
like an ice skating thing
oh yeah that [ __ ] me up you got you
got pretty hurt on that yeah they had
those fat suits
you know like fat [ __ ] or whatever
suits so like you're supposed to be
you know there's nothing bad no harm can
come your way when you're wearing that a
bunch of
bubble wrap so uh it was like this high
speed
pulling winch thing and and you go off a
launch ramp and then
it was like a pyramid of trash cans yeah
and the idea
i think would be you know i basically
just like let
everything go to [ __ ] when you hit the
trash cans but for some reason i'm like
i'm going to land it
i [ __ ] landed on the ice and my one
leg just slipped out and just
[ __ ] blew out my knee really bad damn
did you have any surgery from that
no i just did rehab it was just my mcl
not my acl
huh you can rehab it i remember
considering that
like uh part of like a jackass curse
where if something's been done and then
you just go and reshoot the same thing
that that's when like terrible injuries
happen
and for some reason i thought that that
ice rank thing
was a redo and maybe it was i just
showed it we were already it wasn't my
idea i was like okay
it looked funny it was fun and then it
hurt when when carney
it was it was carney like uh was doing
and
jumping over there he's really good at
ice skating right and so he was jumping
over trash cans it was on an ice skating
rink and he's crashing into charlotte
though but yeah yeah the track it did
have a lot of similarities with that
you're right yeah i didn't think of that
ever
because i had something i did on my own
where 50 cent
threw me down a bunch of concrete stairs
on the bell hop cart
and i somehow miraculously got away with
it he did it three times in a row and i
was fine
and and tremaine loved that footage so
they got me to redo it
and it was redoing it for jackass number
two i had the worst injury
with john waters john waters the
director of like pink flamingos and
hairspray and a bunch of other awesome
movies anyways he
he's like this like kind of smaller like
really nice guy but
hilarious he was cracking us up it's
just so funny all day we're like this
guy's the best
and then he pushes they're both in like
bellhop outfits connie has pushed it for
some reason i don't think
i thought he pushed it i did okay i
think that was all i did he would just
give it a little push and he'd fall down
and then and he had to be taken away in
an ambulance
and john water's just like oh my god
what have i done he was like so bummed
he was dead taking away an ambulance he
was devastated after that
i i bet dude like i i [ __ ] like
landed on the bell hop cart
somehow like didn't even look like
anything and the footage was [ __ ]
in the credits of the movie yeah it
didn't look bad when it happened but it
didn't look bad
it [ __ ] me that's your lower back did
you break any bones i don't know
dude i can't remember i i forget what
they said if there was like
any kind of little fracture all i know
is i was out of commission dude and i
was [ __ ] why i
i wasn't in like so much footage for
that for that second movie
yeah so then when when tremaine came to
me about the fish hook and he was like
hey man like
would you put the hook through your face
again on another day
so we can get more shark footage and and
i was like dude i gotta
like i'm light on footage man i need
yeah i'll do it
because the first time i put the hook
through my face there was me and pontius
and some like
official like body piercer guy who was
like
doing the face piercing and tremaine
hated that he was like it's like here's
his body pieces like who is this guy
he's like
can we do it again where it's just
pontius putting the hook through your
face
you know and like and it'll also really
help us if we do it go out again we can
get more sharks i was in south africa
or the gulf uh that was in the the goal
of the gulf of mexico
off louisiana and so i was like yeah
[ __ ] yeah put the hook through my face
again
the second time and uh and and that was
the second day when when the mako went
from my foot and i kicked the makeover
and that was so lucky because
i was i was off [ __ ] kicking a maker
shark in the face
while we had split cruise and you guys
were doing the riot test
i don't think and and that was like
you're like most like
mom and i can't be a part of it i would
have been with you yeah it was horrible
they did it on a dummy first and i was
and they're like it won't draw blood it
won't break the skin
and i saw it hit that dummy they were
lying they were lying like tore it apart
yeah i remember ryan came up to me after
he's like you're so smart to not do that
he was so bummed he's like i wish i did
not do that
damn who ended up doing it was like
yeah bam done in knoxville dave tapped
out and said he wouldn't do it
bam cried after right it was cry worthy
yeah it's like it's to make prisoners
not want to
leave the you know like riot like when
they just blast you with thousands of
these little
balls right breaks your spirit i
wouldn't it does it's a spirit breaker
there's
a spirit breaker yes i i would not have
done well with that [ __ ] [ __ ]
one thing that comes to mind that you
did that was just i don't know how
gnarly it was but it looked crazy when
you showed up at knoxville's place and
the airbag
like blasted yeah that was a crazy one
because it was my day off
and i had been bugging knoxville for a
long time
back with ipods and you're like it's
just all does this whole music and you
can go like
someone else's computer and just load
all their music onto it so he has so
much awesome music i'm like
just kept bugging him and bugging him
you know i gotta get all your stuff on
my ipod and he's like yeah we'll get
around to it
one day just calls me up in my day up
hey you want to get all that music i'm
like yeah
come on over oh my god so like if you
watch it again you'll see
like it's in my hand it [ __ ] just
goes flying into the street and broke
oh my god you didn't get the music no i
did not get the music i got [ __ ]
knocked in the dog yeah what it was was
the
like the intercom you push the button
you push the button and there's like a
little camera so you're like looking
putting your face
right there to be on camera and it comes
blasting out an airbag high speed airbag
around that thing knocked me out
the same exact day he tells dave england
you want to get all the music
he tells me he goes hey dude hot can you
dress up as a clown or come over to my
house and like [ __ ] yeah
so i put on full clown makeup like the
whole deal had to go over and they just
didn't get a good shot well
oh but did you get hit with that same
thing i did like i think it
wasn't as like direct of a hit you know
like but
i didn't suspect anything
just like
yeah and it was that night too that's
why i went uh when i stripped bam naked
in my apartment was that same night i
was in clown makeup from that same thing
oh wow
in that shot of me uh stripping bam yeah
guess what i have the number 30 ranked
hot sauce on all of
amazon it's called stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon and buy stevo's hot sauce for
your
butthole yeah
yeah dude